(gentle music)
- Check this out.
This is a map
of some of the battery
manufacturing facilities
coming online in the US.
And as you can see,
they're mostly over here.
See, as America tries to rapidly increase
its battery manufacturing capacity,
it's creating what some are
calling America's Battery Belt.
But the decisions around
where to build these factories
is moving America's automotive
heartland further South,
redistributing thousands
of jobs in the process.
So, what are the key factors
shaping where America's Battery Belt is?
Let's find out.
Okay, so first we need to explore
why so many battery factories
are being built in America right now.
See, some battery factories
have been slowly coming online
in the US for years,
but things stepped up
again when Biden signed
the Inflation Reduction Act,
which requires a certain
percentage of a vehicle's battery
be made in America
for it to qualify for federal incentives.
Spending on US battery
factories quadrupled
between 2019 and 2022,
with some $70 billion of investments
for batteries and auto manufacturing
being announced over the last two years.
And more than 15 new battery
factories or expansions
have been announced
since the start of 2021.
So, why are they mostly over here?
Well, given that batteries
are heavy things to ship,
the obvious place to
build battery factories
may seem to be right next
to an automotive plant,
as proximity can reduce
transportation snarls.
That's partly why some
of the new factories
are in a similar area to
existing auto factories.
But proximity is far from the only factor
deciding where these factories should go,
as my colleague Nora Eckert
has been finding out.
- The center of gravity
for the automotive industry
has traditionally been in the Midwest,
around Michigan specifically,
and over time that has shifted
into the American South,
and that's been expedited
with this EV building boom.
- Nora has been chained to site selectors,
essentially the people who decide
where these factories should go.
One key factory is connectivity
to transport networks like railways,
which are far more prevalent
in the East of America.
- For a battery plant or
for an EV assembly plant,
access to railway and ports is key.
- That may explain why these factories
are in the East of America,
but why the move South?
- So, battery plants
and EV assembly plants
require a lot of electricity,
and more than your
traditional gas engine plant.
So the lower electricity costs
in some areas of the South
compared to, say, Michigan,
make that a lot more
attractive for auto makers.
- But perhaps the main factor
pushing these factories South
is whether the sites are turnkey,
essentially, shovel-ready
sites with connected utilities
just waiting to be developed on.
- It's tough to build
up the facility itself
and bring in the workers,
but as long as you've
got that base set up,
it becomes really attractive
for potential auto makers.
- Georgia says it's spent
years prepping projects sites
to attract car companies,
with its Commissioner for
Economic Development saying,
"I feel like we are right
now riding that wave."
All of that has been at about
2/3 of the new auto investment
announced over the past two years
has gone down here to
sites in the US South.
So, what does this mean for
America's automotive heartland
of Michigan and the Great Lakes?
- I think a big question for a
lot of people in the industry
is about Michigan's future
and if it's losing its power
in the automotive industry.
If anything, we're just
seeing the industry
become a little more broadly
dispersed across the US
instead of localized just
in the Michigan area.
- But even with this
race to build factories,
the shift won't happen overnight.
That's because as early movers
in US battery manufacturing have found,
it can take years to train
workers and adapt machinery
to get a factory fully operational.
So even though the
groundwork is being laid now,
it still might take a few years
for America's Battery Belt to truly form.
(gentle music)